un tiers des enseignants en grève
d'après le snuipp-fsu
38 5% selon le ministère de l'éducation
nationale dans les collèges des lycées
23 7 % des enseignants sont mobilisés
selon les autorités tandis que le
premier syndicat du second degré annonce
62 % de grévistes
le personnel des établissements
scolaires dans la rue aujourd'hui un peu
partout en france et notamment à paris
où la manifestation a commencé à 14
heures pour dénoncer les protocoles
sanitaires antico vide à répétition ont
rejoint tout de suite katia technique en
direct du cortège parisien
katia les enseignants sont nombreux on
vient de le voir sur ces images ils ont
répondu à l'appel
[Musique]
paris en effet ils sont des milliers et
des milliers à manifester a défilé sur
le boulevard raspail pour rejoindre le
ministère de la santé pourquoi et bien
parce qu'ils sont à bout ils sont
rejoint ici par deux des parents
d'élèves n'y a pas que les personnels
des établissements scolaires il ya aussi
des parents d'élèves avec des enfants
qui aussi pâtissent de ces protocoles
sanitaires qui sont assouplies qui sont
insuffisants qui changent en permanence
il ya un manque de communication avec le
ministère les directives sont vos
derniers moments et souvent par voie de
presse et puis il ya eu un problème de
moyens ces derniers à passer de masques
pas des basques à ses protecteurs pas de
ffp 2 passes et 2 gêne pas assez
d'hôtesses pas de campagne d'été ce
massif comme l'avait été vantée c'est à
dire que les parents doivent faire
tester leurs enfants eux mêmes à la
pharmacie parfois la veille pour le
lendemain et puis un manque cruel
également de capteur de co2 alors cette
démonstration de force aujourd'hui et
bien elle a eu en effet puisque jean
castex va recevoir tout à l'heure au
ministère de l'éducation nationale des
représentants syndicaux de
l'enseignement de l'éducation nationale
il y aura également jean michel blanquer
rhin et qu on appelle à sa démission en
cortège ne vous le cache pas et puis
également olivier véran en biseau
conférence parce qu'il a le qu'ovide
figurez vous donc voilà l'effet de cette
réunion enfin une communication avec le
gouvernement mais en tout cas pour
aujourd'hui parler des difficultés des
professeurs et bien je vais poser des
questions à fabrice frattini qui est
enseignant en mathématiques il est
également représentant syndical cgt
alors monsieur frattini comment ça se
passe aujourd'hui pour vous concrètement
dans votre établissement scolaire dans
votre lycée alors aujourd'hui nous
sommes massivement en grève ça fait très
longtemps que nous n'avons pas connu ça
les collègues rang non marc on en marre
de de ne pas être protégée par part du
protocole bancaire qui est en fait un
protocole qui s'amenuise au fur et à
mesure que l'épidémie explose nous
n'avons nous sommes quasiment à 10 % de
nos élèves qui sont contaminés au lycée
nous n'avons comme on l'avait dit pas de
moyens de protection si c'était d'ouvrir
les fenêtres en plein hiver nous ne
pouvons pas faire court nous avons froid
nous écrivons avec les doigts gelés que
soient les élèves les enseignants les
conditions ne sont pas réunies pour que
l'école remplisse son rôle d'éducation
à savoir la ministre hier délégué a été
et est attelé nous disaient de c'est un
drame si les écoles ferment à l'heure
actuelle nous avons des effectifs
réduits nous faut en cours avec moins
d'élèves de moins que la moitié de nos
élèves pédagogiquement situer c'est une
honte j'ai honte que mes élèves soient
contaminées à ce point qui n'est aucune
protection pour eux le coc vide est une
maladie neurologique également il ya des
coups violents chez les jeunes je ne
peux pas cautionner que mes élèves
soient en danger à ce point donc donc
oui la grève est massivement suivie dans
d'autres étapes dans scolaire la journée
globalement en france est une réussite
nous n'avons pas vu autant le monde de
l'éducation à ce point dans la rue
donc oui jean michel blanquer a intérêt
à bien comprendre notre détermination
parce qu'elle ne se fera pas aujourd'hui
vous confirmer que l'école et on manque
de tout de tout ce dont je parlais tout
à l'heure c'est à dire les tests des
masques comme il faudrait
exactement
la campagne de testing a toujours été un
échec donc jamais fiable en clair la
reporter sur les pharmacies et les
pharmaciens peuvent le témoigner
c'est là aussi un fiasco terrible avec
des pressions psychologiques sur les
pharmaciens les parents des enfants
c'était d'une violence extrême
donc la seule solution nous avons c'est
d'ouvrir des fenêtres qui sont en fait
pas toujours ouvrables nous faisons le
tour dans l'établissement nous avons des
remontées de la part de nos syndicats il
ya des salles de classe qui ne sont pas
agréables avec un virus a est reporté
avec des masques qui sont mal porter des
masques qui sont insuffisants avec le
vario micron sait très bien qu'à que les
ffp2 qui peuvent vraiment bloqué les
aérosols donc oui nous manquons de tout
et nos enfants ne peuvent pas apprendre
à des conditions normales
merci beaucoup à fabrice frattini donc
qui est professeur de mathématiques dans
un lycée qui souffrent un comme les
élèves et puis évidemment comme les
parents qui sont venus manifester
aujourd'hui aux côtés des enseignants
des directeurs des inspecteurs des
personnels des écoles qui sont ici très
nombreux et donc nous dit nous nous
dirigeons avec eux par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
merci katia technique pour toutes ces
précisions en direct du cortège qui est
parti à 14